mr. worse fun fact yeah we were watching
TV we're watching CNN in our hotel room
in Portland and here comes like a
newscaster a handsome black man wearing
a turtleneck that looks very very very
good on him and Bobby turns to me and he
goes hmm maybe I should buy a few
turtlenecks in serious and then she she
she okay I'm gonna say this I don't
think I so hard I rolled off the bed all
the image of him in a turtleneck to me
is just the funniest thing ever like
that could keep me entertained for the
next 80 years of my life like I'm having
a bad day and I just am in a turtleneck
okay okay I'll cross you cross the line
you just crossed the line let me see
something something right now okay
that number one you've never seen me in
a turtleneck I know but you've never
seen me in one okay so you're making
assumptions you're you're making here
there's an image in your mind there may
or may not be true and number two it's
not as if I was gonna go I'm gonna go to
the gap and get a [ __ ] turtle I don't
know where to buy one yeah where'd you
get those this black I just kind of look
when black people were turning out they
look like theatrical like oh yeah yeah
they look like yeah that's a pretty good
look right there maybe I should worry
and then as soon as I did that she rolls
off the bed and she just convulsions as
if it was the funniest thing she had
ever heard enough [ __ ] okay I'm
offended Bobby I am pleading and begging
alright anyone wants to go send me a
[ __ ] turtleneck November 19th cent
Bobby a turtleneck November 19 on
molestation day and also on a bus
station day and also I will wear it for
the podcast just to prove it looks damn
[ __ ] good damn [ __ ] good okay but
um that's crazy that you would even say
something like that baby what have you
wanted to turn back oh yeah of course in
return they look spectacular on
Wow both daytime just a really good
boyfriend what I really am hey just
watch the og documentary guys I mean did
this weekend I took her shopping I
bought our nice jacket hmm right vintage
vintage one and I just give her good
meals and I'm just man do I get the same
I don't know one time you just wanna you
don't think about a turtle man right cuz
yesterday was our anniversary
official-official kalila and i oh we
spent it in the heart and she said the
most special no before that she said the
most selfish thing I've ever heard in my
life it was so last night you know I've
been on the road okay I don't know if
you guys know this but Tuesdays and
Thursdays I'm not allowed to play
destiny mm-hmm it's the arrangement that
was made because relationships are all
about compromise life coach Bobby all
right guys listen
so last night anniversary and I go I'm
gonna go play baby
I was also I've been out on the road I
couldn't play this weekend I was in
Portland Thursday to its first half he
didn't remember of course yeah how
selfish is that what that she wanted me
to cuddle and watch something with her
when she knows that my destiny time has
already been cut in two by Portland by
Portland and also these two [ __ ] hell
days Tuesdays and Thursdays you know
because I'm a good person
yeah I mean right back me up let the man
play no yeah look at her
go look at Cody I want to buy you food
after this so many cakes
she loves cakes so auntie auntie listen
to what your little nephew says okay but
you know what baby
I found the text of you asking me to be
your girlfriend
yes beautiful great it no keep talking
because I still have to find you just to
find it
[Music]